you
all right we have a small crew at the
start at least for a one-minute
tournament thirty minutes of a
one-minute chess let's see what we get
what kind of action okay let's build a
center grab some space space invaders he
wants to be on d3 I want to crack with
that for right away
more space give me the space there we go
g5 incoming more space more space
probably have to sack yes
leading to mate if they take the h-file
will be ripped open soon kingi to rook
h1 h5 now they're sacking let's just
develop the queen strike at the knight
look to get in here I guess I still want
my rook on each one my king is opposite
the rook but Queen has to take now it's
mate next bishop has to block too much
space I guess that was the big issue
after f4 f5 because there wasn't any ooh
Ferrari how do you like that no no no
we're not gonna take there he wants me
to do that
we played too many of those positions No
all right let's weasel my dark-squared
bishop around okay
I want the d5 square they're gonna break
down my light squares very soon it's
official
down on d5 I think they have to take
okay I feel like I get scooped up this
pond and then I have some control right
now
let's open up this diagonal for my
bishop okay
taking this square get on the G file I'm
taking this square where's the mate
where is that mate there's a check I'm
not sure what that move is doing I know
now I'm just being fancy there maybe
that's a good move at the end hmm or not
I didn't see that hmm I'm in big trouble
they only have 11 seconds at least they
went into the think tank let's give a
check hey went into the think tank do
they have enough time probably right
it's probably
idea I got their queen sneaky oh man
sneaky town wide six seconds I put some
heat on them they were thinking they
were thinking that's what I had to do
okay we got 28 players in here and a
beast well one of them at least is a
beast and a half the Ferrari alrighty
yeah that wasn't cool my my fancy move
kind of you know taunting was that a
little bit of taunting there saying how
you can't you can't take because there's
a pin and everything he shut that right
down we got beef or hitting prying open
the Kings side or their King position
let's say and then I'll smash through on
c3 let's add some more fuel to c3 mmm
Queen trade huh I got this square
covered
now we take oh hang on hang on see what
I did there maybe I could have allowed
that but yeah let's do this
keep that Knight boxed out not here if
Knight c3 I can you'll be safe here but
avoid the rook exchange if that was if
they exchanged I was gonna go rook to b8
Knight f5 is a good spot this is a
nothing move I get some basically
passing with that move there we go
I don't know how good it is but let's
target these light squares can't defend
that pawn now less than 10 the rook take
a knight watch out for disc
Ruiz on the bishop defend this guy okay
they don't have any time back determine
big time edge in that one got eight
plenty of time left 24 on the nose 29
players in this one
can we get a pairing any moment I see DJ
chess dog is here okay
terminal TZ terminal okay
some more space in this game let's see
if we could convert that space into
something good here and a try for this
again this wasn't my first opponent was
it maybe
let's break right now take that night if
the bishop blocks let's develop okay get
the rook right here I guess that clean
can't go too far they have some good
dark square control let's point at h7
Queen f4 defends on h2 c5 ascend
if I have a passed pawn the rook is out
of play should take with the bishop I'm
just doing this to cut the rook off okay
um they're offering a draw I definitely
don't want to draw should probably get
my King involved sometime uh here's okay
I guess we're gonna have a rook trade
mm-hmm maybe not I had a rook going down
to the eighth-ranked idea okay
d4 this is the pawn break to get in have
their king cut off hmm
this guy is running now how'd he stop
that guy he's fast can now be stopped
yes he could
I could insist though they've 12 seconds
to work it out yeah not enough time just
take and push through King isn't there
to stop him
trying to deflect me way I could have
captured probably still all right would
you stop with these checks back
determine all right we got 12 21 change
where is the Ferrari he's not on page
one yet d4
you apply Oda the Dutch stunned me there
let's try for this uh gambit here g4
looking at that h-file orgy file
queenside castles the idea they live in
really dangerous here putting the Queen
and the king on the same diagonal or
file and what am i doing I'm putting
them on the same okay let's go here on
c7 and here we go into e6 and then g7
next tough spot bishop movement and I'm
crashing through here no they could take
with the bishop and defend okay
I want to get I want to get this pawn up
in Bishop here no I just dropped my
knight no good man not good to drop your
knight
they're in a tough spot still their
queen is close to being trapped it's not
this pawn down I have a bishop block or
even this one throwing a punch back
now we'll crash through here hit the
Queen who's close to dead rook here
looking for me yeah we got me Bishop ER
on after block they resigned back to
tournament h3 and g4 against the Dutch I
don't have to go Kings side notice how
that Queen on c2 and the rook on h1 if
they capture on g4 they would be
converging on h7 checks and mix okay I
got sixteen I see Ferrari there in
fourth top eight I'll have fire my
opponent moved I didn't realize
let's invite a third pond into the mix
here it's Castle I like how my mouse is
doing its hang onto that fish up take
with the night let's kick him away and
then jump in here with tempo and the
long diagonal maybe drift over towards
the Kings side grab some more space
opposite their king let's just keep it
fluid in the center here
and stay opposite their king
flight square and now we're gonna look
for something like this to open it up
and then maybe smash through like this
around the Queen
it's block oh no I thought I was winning
that I'm not there Knight is there to
defend I'm hitting this pawn three times
night there is excellent I have a strong
night he's passed now maybe the wrong
pawn to take with enough defense it's
killer night stop Knight f4 throw some
punches at the rook c4 week square and
now the rook is dead just like that
under 15 for my opponent alright I'm up
a rook and yes we'll take this guy yeah
pushing here let's just take that night
out and where's the mate just push this
guy a little bit no time back to
tournament 2016 16 all fire VIN VIN
withdrew what's up with that maybe a
connection issue ooh no wonder Ferrari
wasn't on the front page for a little
bit he had back-to-back speed bumps so
oh we didn't get paired in the first
round so okay well we're gonna get
paired up now he just jumped up there I
saw 38 players 16 minutes 50 seconds now
there we go let's try b4 just let's just
give him a different structure to stare
at something that maybe he's not as
comfortable with maybe is the keyword
maybe let's keep the knight out of B
form okay
think I could do this yeah it feels a
little bit loose though it must be said
yeah I want my knight on d4 can I make
that happen
scary hey we're in the think tank a
little bit there right on d4 is strong
let's get a flight square mmm don't like
having to do that there Queen's gonna
come in now scary very scary what's
going on right now hello boy I think you
have to try for this Bishop check
Misha block I have to restrict that
night okay
all right what's the time situation not
good yeah this is gonna be painful oh
boy
Kings running for his life and get it
Queen trade though it's forced King up
slight time edge
with that
oh they got away oh they're down at I'm
at six seconds again Oh were you
expecting me to commentate that game
you're crazy
23 22 17 16 14 minutes 14 seconds ah man
what I should just mmm
what are you trying to say I should have
kept the rooks on I didn't see that rook
up and over tactic it wasn't a tactic
but you know where it grabbed a pawn and
then forced the rook trade ah okay and I
don't even know what's going on here
okay let's get a flight Square save my
h7 pond where is he going
let's take him out and throw a punch at
that night see what he does hmm all
right in the center hit it the knight
again clean is really strong right here
really strong each - f - C 5 what isn't
she hitting here that's a safe square ok
guess we'll go here and then try to
track down the c5 pawn I'm doing this to
stop b4 I want my knight in to c5 let's
get a little closer I don't want to move
my knight too quick now I have a couple
squares to get into c5 they only took
away one they have this move they don't
have much time now get hit that pond
twice first
getting another pond more ponds for the
night even more ponds pac-man mode
engaged
23:20 the beast again what can I throw
at this guy how about this let's run
this okay let's let's grab some space on
the kingside castle shutting things down
he's gonna grab that pond probably could
have let's kill that night it's coming
at me with g5 let's do this though hit
him with a fork make him think maybe can
we make the guy think Bishop h5 it's
getting serious it's very serious now
big trouble for Team black no they're
really in the think tank there mm-hmm
what a slum of that is that I just did
and that one let's hit this pawn my
Knights are garbage I can't I can't even
get my Knights working really there we
go now we're gonna do something if the
Queen crash through here
pins we got a pawn move whit's check the
rook is one and got it under control
plenty of time more pieces a check here
just don't fall
mate I have a bishop block and already
let the clean defend their clean
exchange I am fine with where's the mate
no time down it and down on time okay
twenty six twenty five twenty three less
than ten this tournament I okay got fire
only a one-point lead not much
let's try Sicilian okay you could score
a quick one here
okay it's vulnerable bishop going
queenside they are
that's a problem we got a piece Knight
takes pawn that's a bad one to pre move
don't remove that oh that's interesting
hmm gonna hit me with a fork
Queen takes pawn I guess should have
mate somehow let's get rid of this
Knight
it's kind of gluing everything together
all right now everything's under control
a really strong night Co means ready to
enter somehow or another Forks every
which way let's try that
that's me back to tournament 31-point
lead still eat and change Ferraris at
23:00 han and samuel san thorry is there
40 players at the moment let's see what
we get yeah VIN VIN is still out maybe a
connection issue I'm not sure chess
player 1909 on board let's try knight c6
here okay I guess see what we got here
some scotch Bishop on c5
my bishop that's a bad free move give me
the a file starting to smash open their
structure this cannot be good hitting at
e3 now may want to target it again with
Knight g4 I don't see why not
how they defend that got him overnight
they're not so I scooped up that pawn
this is still an excellent spot for a
knight may want to fork let's just
castle first knights a really strong
piece close to being trapped I could
have played pawn up now I could rescue
him this way
come out otherwise this is too strong of
a post a five fish of a six and we got a
for coming
not quite let's just keep it really
simple could have captured that pond
Kings in the center about couple ponds
now and double up let's give a check and
then I guess we'll take here okay with
trades improve the King a little bit
give it a check and focus on this square
no stalemates
all right there down that time 3433 this
guy isn't going away okay I don't know
if I want to know let's see if he maybe
feels pressed to a berserk there's still
time for a few more games 540 who's he
playing against okay let's try a form
this guy's berserk me this was maybe one
two berserk I didn't I didn't catch that
in time that they were berserk you me
know their bishops dead no it's not no
it's not dead let's go Queen side
throughout c4 c5 Adam maybe now it's
hitting when a fork right that's pretty
that's looking serious let's insist I'm
pushing through here let's get my King
off the same file first night where are
you going he doesn't have many squares
lose the Queen if you take here twice
let's do that well isn't
seconds chase the Queen away no there is
that check isn't there okay anything
just burn their time time burners yeah I
should have berserk back 38 okay well
that guy slipped up he had a draw so I
have fire 38 a three-point lead 38 35 34
and change who's next okay this is the
guy in second place this is important
all right let's grab some space three
pawns in the center and maybe I'd take
that night out go for b5 let's hit that
Queen first get on the B file
maybe b3 I want to restrict that night
hmm looking at a fork I could have
after the Queen that would have been
pretty good too just pretty good oh hi
why not take the clean watch out for
Queen g5 9f5 sneaky town let's just get
that clean out of here it's double up
first prove the king where does my
knight want to be that's a good
reposition that they're doing at their
Bishop my knight wants to be on g5 I
have the B file under control I'm on my
queen on f4 next Queen trade that Knight
is in a tough spot and if they go to the
back rank they didn't
let's hit the Queen first get her out of
there now we take advantage of the pin
all right let's take twice let's get rid
of that bishop and this pawn and be sure
to track that pawn down soon just push
him away um yeah I'll take here first
let's just save everything and then
we're gonna be pushing the C pawn soon
watch out for steel mates no stalemates
no still mates and they resigned back to
tournament 42 with fire 35 33 one minute
50 left all right let's see if we could
finish strong who are we gonna get as a
final game Ferrari I guess I think he
just jumped up there oh he could catch
me he could catch me
oh no oh he could catch me this isn't
the player I want to go against
I'm losing a pond I'm losing a pond not
cool maybe I could no no fry my way if
it comes down to that maybe I could no
no fry my way to victory less than 40 um
let's try to submit my knight in there
you know let's let's do it like this see
for it will be undermined now if I do it
right away with b5 they're really
thinking here okay now let's do this
pawn push I have this move I should
maybe set that up
oh they missed it Queens now I'm
protected yeah I got a queen and they
just helped me to me back to tournament
46 43 and that's going to do it whoo you
played a lot of games myself in Ferrari
3 or 4 goose eggs all right 46 43 thirty
seven in total 42 players in this one
let's have a look at page two three four
and five
all right